voilà bien alors je mange jalons
regardez moi bien j'étais encensé par
tout le monde vous êtes devenu
intouchable et tué une icône
alors on va faire l'interview brûlons
les idoles alors jeanne qui aurait pu
vous remplacer dans les rois maudits
célarié orapi qu'est ce que vous ne
savez pas jouer les jeunes filles donc
le film vous trouvez-vous très mauvaise
dans un film un que j'ai ton le paletot
du nigeria le paltoquet ouais d'accord
au casting de quel film avez vous été
refusée un film avec rené clair la
beauté du diable
ils ont plus qu il ya la place jean j'ai
oublié son nom innocence non parce
qu'après la part et d'autre 20 ça
n'intéresse pas beaucoup
non mais ça la grèce aux cadeaux c'est
vrai quel homme à repousser vos avances
ou j'en connais pas oh
alors j'ai appris un truc savait pas
c'est j'en connaissais beaucoup et puis
pas des moindres mais je savais par gêne
ni nier ces normes
jeanine et je trouve ça formidable parce
qu'il s'agit ni j'ai beaucoup
d'admiration pour lui et un jour vous
êtes dans le bureau de roger nimier je
sais plus qui vient le bureau et ils
vous planque sous le bureau pendant que
son invité la gare vers des valois et je
grimpais par la fenêtre je n'entrais pas
par la suite ya un petit caillou pour
dire que tu vas là et il a voulu faire
une surprise et j'étais sur la table
pendant leur conversation
roger nimier pour quelles raisons vous
êtes ont quitté généralement sa part est
prétentieux mais dès que je sentais la
fin venir éventuel je partais que les
ruptures du fou
l'impatience l'autorité qu'on supporte
mal chez une femme et
l'autonomie sur glace marine
l'indépendance ouais ouais j'ai eu
recours à la chirurgie esthétique
une fois oui pour faire quoi un homme de
lifting comme ça moi je vous fait des
caprices de stars n'ont jamais non
j'aime trop être à l'heure g une
discipline de fer
quand ma prise très très jeune j'y tiens
beaucoup sinon je craque
bon ça veut pas ça les religieuses et
puis pour l'épater l'air et puis la
comédie française je suis à bonne école
sacré quoi on est ici de bull evidian
l'onu paris